in the first version of the videos of
the proof of the derivatives of the
natural law natural log of X natural log
of X where the first time I prove this
is a couple years ago and I'd the very
next video I prove that the derivative
of e to the X is equal to e DX I've been
charged with some of making a circular
proof and I'm pretty convinced that my
proof wasn't circular so what I want to
do in this video now that I have a
little bit more space to work with a
little bit more sophisticated tools I'm
going to redo the proof and I'm going to
do these in the same video to show you
at no point do I assume this before I
actually show it so let's start with the
proof so the first thing I need to do is
prove this thing up here and I want to
keep track of this I don't assume this
until I actually show it so let's start
with the proof the derivative of the
natural log of X so the derivative of
the natural log of X we can just go to
the basic definition of a derivative
it's equal to the limit as Delta X
approaches 0 of the natural log of X
plus Delta X minus the natural log of X
all of that over Delta X now we can just
use the property of logarithms if I have
the log of a minus the log of B that's
the same thing as the log of a over B so
let me rewrite it that way so this is
going to be equal to the limit limit as
Delta X approaches 0 I could take this 1
over Delta X right here 1 over Delta x
times the natural log of X plus Delta X
divided by this X just doing the
logarithm properties right there and
then I can rewrite this first of all
when I have this coefficient in front of
a logarithm I can make this the exponent
and then I can simplify this in here so
this is going to be equal to the limit
as Delta X approaches 0 of the natural
log when we do this in a new color
let me do in a completely new color the
natural log of the inside here I'll just
divide everything by X so X divided by X
is 1 and then plus Delta X over X and
then I had this 1 over Delta X sitting
out here and I could make that the
exponent that's just an exponent rule
right there
or a logarithm property 1 over Delta X
now I'm going to make a substitution
remember all of this this was all you
know just from my my definition of a
derivative this was all equal to the
derivative of the natural log of X I
have still yet to in any way use this
and I won't use that until I actually
show it to you and I've become very
defensive about these claims of
circularity and you know they're my
fault because that shows that I wasn't
clear enough in my earlier versions of
these proofs so I'll try to be more
clear this time so let's see if we can
simplify this into terms that we
recognize let's make the substitution so
that we can get the e and maybe terms
that we recognize let's make the
substitution Delta x over X is equal to
1 over n if we multiple this is the same
thing this is the equivalent
substitution if we multiply both sides
of this by X as saying that Delta X is
equal to x over n these are equivalent
statements I just multiplied both sides
by X here now if we take the limit the
limit as n approaches infinity of this
term right here that's equivalent that's
completely equivalent to taking the
limit as Delta X approaches 0 limit as
Delta X approaches 0 if we're defining
Delta X to be this thing and we take the
limit as its denominator approaches 0
we're going to make Delta X go to 0 so
let's make that substitution so all of
this is going to be equal to the limit
as now we've gotten rid of our Delta X
we're going to say the limit is n
approaches infinity of the natural log
I'll go back to that move color
natural log of 1 plus now I said that
instead of Delta X over X I made the
substitution that that is equal to 1
over N so that's 1 plus 1 over N and
then what's 1 over Delta X well Delta X
is equal to x over N so 1 over Delta X
is going to be the inverse of this it's
going to be n over X and then we can
just rewrite this expression right here
let me rewrite it again this is equal to
the limit as n approaches infinity of
the natural log of 1 plus 1 over N and
what I can do is I can separate out this
end from the 1 over X so I could say
this is to the N and then all of this to
the 1 over X and once again this is just
an exponent property right if I raise
something to the N and then to the 1
over X I could just multiply the
exponents and get to the N over X so
these two statements are equivalent but
now we can use logarithm properties to
say hey if I this is the exponent I can
just stick it out in front of the
coefficient right here I could put it
out right there so we get and just
remember we this was all the derivative
with respect to X of the natural log of
X so what is that equal to we could put
this one out of X in front here in fact
that one out of X term it has nothing to
do with n it's kind of a constant term
when you think of it in terms of n so we
could actually put it all the way out
here we could put it either place so we
could say 1 over x times all that stuff
and move the limit as n approaches
infinity of the natural log of 1 plus 1
over N to the N the natural log of all
of that stuff or just to make the point
clear we can write rewrite this part let
me make that salmon color n equal to 1
over x times the natural log of the
limit as n approaches infinity I'm just
switching places here because obviously
what we care is what happens to this
term as it approaches infinity of 1 plus
1 over N
to the end well what is this should look
for a little familiar to you on some of
the first videos where we talked about e
this is one of the definitions of e e is
defined and I'm just being clear here
I'm not I'm still not using this at all
I'm just stating that e is the
definition of e e is equal to the limit
as n approaches infinity of 1 plus 1
over N to the end this is just the
definition of E and natural log is
defined to be the logarithm of base this
thing so if I'm taking the net so this
thing is e so I'm saying that the
derivative of the natural log of X is
equal to 1 over x times the natural log
this thing right here is e that's what e
the definition of e is I'm not using the
definition of the derivative of E or the
definition of the derivative of e to the
X I'm just using the definition of E and
the definition of natural log is log
base E so obviously when this is asking
this says the power that you have to
raise e to to get to e well this is just
equal to 1 and there we get that the
derivative of the natural log of X is
equal to 1 over X so so far I think
you'll be satisfied that we've proven
this first statement up here and in no
way did we use this statement right here
I just use the definition of e but
that's fine and I mean we assumed we
know the definition of you even when we
just talk about natural log we assume
that it's base e in no way did I assume
this to begin with
now given that we've shown this and we
didn't assume this at all let's see if
we can show this so the derivative let's
do a little bit a little bit of an
exercise here and let me get make some
actually I could probably do it in the
margins let's take the derivative of
this function the natural log of e to
the X the natural log of e to the X so
there's two ways we can approach this
the first way we could simplify this and
we could say this is the exact same
thing as the derivative we could put
this X out front
of X times the natural log of e and
what's the natural log of e the natural
log of e we already know is equal to
it's equal to one so this is just the
derivative of X and the derivative of X
is equal to one so that's pretty
straightforward the derivative we just
this is just you know we no way did we
assume this to begin with we just
simplify this expression to just this is
the same thing as the derivative of X
because this term cancels out and the
derivative X is just 1 or we could view
it the other way we could do the chain
rule we could say that this could be
viewed as the derivative of this inner
function of this inner expression so the
derivative the expression I don't know
what that is I'm not assuming anything
about it I just don't know what it is so
I'll write it in yellow right here so
it's equal to the derivative with
respect to X of e to the X I don't know
what this is I have no clue what this is
and I haven't assumed anything about
what it is I'm just using the chain rule
it's the derivative of this inside
function with respect to X which is this
right here times the derivative of this
outside function with respect to the
inside function so the derivative of
natural log of X with respect to X is 1
over X so the derivative of natural log
of anything with respect to anything is
1 over that anything so it's going to be
equal to so the derivative of natural
log of X with respect to e to the X is
equal to 1 over 1 over e to the X once
again i knowwe assumed this right here
in no way have so fired anything we've
done we haven't assumed that but clearly
my derivatives either way I solve it and
one way I solved it I got one the other
way I kind of didn't solve it I got this
expression right here they must be equal
to each other so let me write that down
this must be equal to that it's just we
just look at it two different ways and
got two different results but I still
don't know what this thing is I just
left it kind of open-ended of e to the X
happens to be but we know since these
two expressions are equal we know that
the derivative with respect to X
of whatever e to the X so whatever the
derivative of with respect to X of e to
the X happens to be we know that when we
multiply that times 1 over e to the X
that's when we just did the chain rule
that we get we should get the same
result as when we approach the problem
the other way that should be equal to
this approach because they're they're
both different ways of looking at the
derivative of the natural log of e to
the X so that should be equal to 1 well
we're almost there we could just
simplify this and solve for our mystery
derivative of e to the X multiply both
sides of this equation by e to the X and
you get the derivative with respect to X
of e to the X is equal to e to the X and
I want to clarify this you know and at
no point in this entire proof at no
point did I assume this did I assume
this in fact this is the first time that
I'm even making that I'm making the
statement I didn't have to assume this
when I showed you that the GNAT
derivative of the natural log of X is 1
over X and I didn't have to show it I
didn't have to assume this to kind of
get to it so in no way is this proof
circular so anyway I didn't want to
appear defensive but I wanted to clarify
this up because I you know I don't want
to in any way blame those who think that
my original proof was circular it's my
fault because I didn't explain it
properly so hopefully this should
provide a little bit of clarity on the
issue